thank you very much excellencies ladies
and gentlemen
first of all i would like to salute the
determination and the commitment of who
members
as well as yours personally dear dr
tedros
you and your team have worked tirelessly
to uphold the multilateral framework
that is so essential for global health
security
even when it was difficult to do so
the spirit of collective action is the
only true robust answer to fight this
pandemic
and to fight future pandemics
we started some of that work at the g20
global health summit in may
where the world's major economies vowed
to work together to make this the last
global pandemic
and with the rome declaration signed on
that day we committed to learning the
lessons from this pandemic and to be
better prepared for the future
and this is why i welcome the world
health assembly's decision on to start
negotiations
towards an international agreement or
other international instrument
to strengthen pandemic prevention
preparedness and response
i also support targeted improvements to
the 2005 international health
regulations
an overall strengthening of the who so
important
and the establishment of a new financial
interim intermediary fund
for global health security and pandemic
preparedness
from our side the european commission
looks forward
to inclusive multilateral negotiations
starting next year
but there can be no stand still in a
pandemic and we still have urgent tasks
ahead of us
as we speak
the global community is faced with the
threat of a new
highly transmissible variant of covet 19
omicron
this is not the first variant and this
time the world showed it is learning
and i want to say explicitly
that i'm personally grateful to the
leadership of president cyril ramaphosa
for that
south africa's analytic world work and
transparency in sharing its results
was indispensable in allowing a swift
global response
it no doubt saved many lives
and it is a model of how international
cooperation should work in the face of
cross-border health threats
because only collective effective and
immediate responses
can work against viruses that of course
do not respect either borders or good
intentions
at the global health summit in may
we agreed to uphold the principles of
equity and good governance
we agreed to make multilateral
cooperation and solidarity the only
viable way forward
the g20 summit repeated that pledge last
month in rome
and you can count on the european union
to make good on that
the european union and its member states
will work very hard to achieve the
global vaccination target of 70 in 2022
agreed at the recent g20 summit
and we will support capacity building
for sequencing testing treatments and of
course vaccination
we know we can get there and we will
make sure we do
and this is why europe's aims at
sharing at least
700 million doses of vaccines by mid
2022
with low and middle income countries
it is why we helped create the act
accelerator and provided 3 billion euro
funding especially for global
vaccination through covax
and it is also why we are investing
heavily in vaccine manufacturing in
africa
and we are also engaging on vaccine
manufacturing with south america
together with our partners
we will do everything needed to overcome
this pandemic and to be better prepared
for the future
i wish you a successful world health
assembly you have an important work
ahead of you and i very much thank you
for your attention